this article is so serious yeah we can
only have someone like Nick this is not
yes that decision so we're just gonna
let him take over
Nick you're gonna have to hold these
both your hands when you do this article
please is that for car batteries go
ahead when you guys were kids did you
guys have any uh jobs Target how old
were you 17. what about you Anthony
I worked at Knott's Berry Farm what
about you
it's a clean pool
but we can't laugh though migrant child
labor found at many U.S Brands like
Cheerios in America yeah in America
[Applause]
yeah I think you know I think it's
totally okay for kids to have jobs but
I'm assuming I'm assuming this is bad
because these these kids are being
exploited
[Laughter]
they are